all right so with the Oscar nominations
being announced about a week ago Kate
blanchett's tar gobbled up a handful of
Noms and this isn't your typical dry
drama no this wasn't marketed well at
all because this is a psychological
drama tense cancel culture thriller so
we're gonna be breaking this thing down
for you explaining the ending some of
its themes and why the heck there's a
ghost creeping on Lydia tar
[Music]
but with all of that out of the way a
huge thank you for clicking this I'm
your host Jared now let's get into tar
so tar follows Kate blanchett's Lydia
tar essentially being at the top of her
game an accomplished composer pianist
musicologist and the first female Chief
conductor of the Berlin film harmonic we
see her relishing in all of these
accomplishments being interviewed at the
New Yorker Festival promoting a handful
of projects two noteworthy ones are her
new book tar on tar which just screams
that Obama awarding himself with a metal
Meme and her upcoming live recording of
mahler's Fifth Symphony however with
this level of Fame and expertise we soon
learned Lydia may have a bit of a dark
side or past tour sure being a bit
demanding when it comes to the do's and
don'ts of the stuff involving her
upcoming Symphony but very much Badgers
one of her bypoc pan gender students
about their influences in composers
urging them to focus on their art rather
than the transgressions they may or may
not have committed did in their personal
lives this of course is quite an on the
nose concept for Lydia to suggest
because she too has a clouded past
revolving around a past student of hers
named Krista Taylor that she became
romantically involved with Krista was
then blacklisted from all of these other
orchestras by her after the two had a
falling out Lydia believes that her
professional and personal lives should
be separate but can't help but mix the
two as the same series of events similar
to what happened with Krista begin to
happen with a young new Russian cellist
named Olga manipulating the auditions
Lydia firmly plants Olga in the first
chair position granting her a solo in
the symphony's companion piece
alienating her relationship with Sharon
her wife and concert Master of the
orchestra the Alien Nation continues
though as Lydia is informed via her
assistant Francesca that Krista Taylor
had ended her life and her parents were
attempting to sue Lydia after a number
of alarm farming Acquisitions against
her came out lady instructs Francesca to
delete any email she has with Krista she
doesn't instead quitting after failing
to get the assistant conductor position
that she was promised and leaks the
emails a series of bad presses thrown
Lydia's way as she has to deal with the
Krista suit against her then an edited
out of context video of her berating the
student from earlier with accusations of
racism protests against her during her
book promotional tour Shannon leaving
her and not permitting Lydia to see
their daughter finally leading to Lydia
being replaced as the conductor for the
big upcoming miler's Fifth Symphony
making a huge scene tackling and
assaulting her replacement the night of
the performance which was so reminiscent
of the ending sequence from Whiplash
like so well done here now advise to lay
low after the events by her
representation the ending is a pretty
big shocker as it's revealed that
Lydia's not from some prestigious line
of Rich pretentious Elite composers but
rather returns to her childhood home on
Staten Island where her brother calls
her by a real name Linda Tarr showing us
that almost all of Lydia was faked until
you make it approach a charade if you
will forgetting her Roots at the end of
it all months later in a complete change
of scenery as we see Lydia now living
her life in the Philippines a foreign
land where no one knows who she is
essentially Starting Over Again
symbolized by the Leonard Bernstein tape
what does music mean that she watched
back in her childhood room this is
supposed to be Lydia starting Anew
however her past ways may not entirely
be washed away as she wanders into a
high-end brothel looking for a massage
this ties back to her manipulative
behavior and preying on younger women
with Krista and Olga as she eyes a young
woman who is sitting in the exact same
position as Olga was in the orchestra
alignment and sports a number five on
our robe referring back to the Fifth
Symphony that Lydia did not get to
conduct ending the story in the most
ironic head-scratching scene of the
entire movie is now seeing Lydia perform
once again but it is drastically
different than the high class snooty
Rich Orchestra goers that we saw from
earlier no no no these are cosplayers
attending a comic-con-like convention
for the Monster Hunter video game series
as she conducts the orchestra in the
same determined serious Banner playing
the theme song of the Game ending the
film you're probably thinking what the
hell did I just watch and believe me
there's a lot to unpack with this for
sure first of which is a look at the
idea of power corruption abuse leading
us into the hashtag metoo movement of
things Lydia is essentially someone who
gained such power power in the musical
world her influence alone gained her
notoriety from performances to even her
book sales but at what moment does that
power become too much for one person and
they start to manipulate things because
they simply can in an interview with
radio times director Todd field
explained I always knew where I'd
started and where it would end and I
wanted to take a person and make them a
vessel for having to hold power and when
does that vessel start to crack you know
and in what Manner does the vessel go
from being something on a pedestal and
sort of literally worshiped to being
stuck in the garage though tar is
entirely a fictionalized character story
blah blah blah there are some serious
similarities to celebrities and other
powerful figureheads that fall right
into the mold of Lydia tar from Cosby to
Weinstein to Louis CK the list goes on
and on and on and with most of these
cases these people of Power are torn
down down or quote canceled and the film
even shows the concept of cancer culture
but in a really clever way because yes
Lydia has lost her foothold in the
prestigious musical world after being
canceled she's lost opportunities
relationships Fame there are crowds of
protesters for her book and even legal
trouble with the passing of Krista
mostly being blamed on Lydia it's also
pretty on the nose for her to be
orchestrating for a game called Monster
Hunter at the very end when she was
actually the monster of this entire
story being exposed and now seeing how
far she's fallen from the prestigious
world that she was so secure it but also
how cancel culture isn't necessarily a
hundred percent foolproof plan in many
cases the Persona in question can lay
low and come back without a single
problem sure they may have to reinvent
themselves a bit which tar showcases in
a very satirical way for example Lydia
going back back to her childhood Roots
shifting to a different country and
conducting an orchestra for Monster
Hunter she is still putting her heart
and soul and seriousness into the craft
as long as it sounds good the Monster
Hunter Fans don't give two pumps who
this person is and Hell think about the
real life stories involving this same
exact thing how many of them were
actually truly quote canceled Louis CK
did some heinous
but literally just sold out Madison
Square Garden like why how this also
brings up the concept Lydia tar
questioned her students about can you or
rather should we be able to separate the
artist from the art someone's personal
life and reputation should it be in
question when they release an absolute
Banger of a song a movie a painting and
so forth in doing so the culture of the
time and place that that art was created
is then forgotten therefore important
material in the past wouldn't have the
same cultural impact that it does in the
present this is actually kind of
elaborated on during the opening New
Yorker interview chapipo kneebo only
receive an icaro or song and in that way
the past and the present converge it's
the flip sides of the same Cosmic coin
and lastly we gotta talk about what the
hell these ghosts just creeping about
mean
the first time I watched this I honestly
thought I was I was seeing things but on
two separate occasions a mysterious
figure can be seen in the background of
Lydia's apartment and once again when
she wakes up in the middle of the night
there is also the scream in the park
Lydia here as well on the jog which fun
fact this is the same scream from The
Blair Witch Project
[Music]
so these horror elements are to
symbolized Lydia's past specifically
Krista who is the young Protege Lydia
used and abused eventually taking her
own life she is haunting Lydia Christus
fate was actually teased by the book
that she had gifted Lydia a bit of a
history lesson right now but the novel
is the challenge and was inspired by
Vida Sackville West passionate love
affair with Violet trephasis in the
early 1900s the dedication page in
Romani dialect translates to the book is
yours my witch read it and you will find
your tormented Soul changed and free in
the novel and in real life Violet often
threatened ending her own life if Vida
left her Lydia knows this alluding to
Krista eventually unaliving the pattern
scribbled in the novel is also a shipabo
origin which I'll touch on in a little
bit but it's Krista urging Lydia to come
clean now throughout out most of the
movie Lydia never really thinks dwells
even talks about the immoral things that
she did to get where she's at now and
vice versa what she's taken advantage of
while in this position of power all of
this haunting is actually her conscience
hallucinating these things to show her
inner guilt even though her outside
Persona that she built up doesn't
physically want to approach these things
head on almost acting like a robot
emotionless making excuses for the other
party's feelings but these subtle hints
are shown the two times we see the
ghosts of Krista in the apartment also
when Lydia is constantly looking over
her shoulder feeling like someone's
there the scream in the park the several
times she can't sleep blaming it on a
handful of random noises in her
apartment her coming back to reality and
gripping the chair right as the New
Yorker interview is happening even the
dog she runs into when she's at Olga's
place is just another image she
hallucinates a black dog is actually
typically associate with the feeling of
grief or sadness predators are typically
haunted by what they do so in Lydia's
case haunted and having a conscience are
almost like one in the same and the
major turning point here is when she
slams her head it's almost like the
Predator now is now turning into the
prey as everything slowly unravels for
Lydia surprisingly right before the fall
is the weird dreamlike sequence of Lydia
on her bed in the swamp with a snake
swimming towards her for the ship above
serpents or snakes are entities that
cleanse and purify their state of being
and are commonly seen flowing within
their Visions they're also sacred
creatures specifically the cosmic
Serpent of ronin and are considered the
source of all patterns as they are laid
out upon its skin these various patterns
show up several times throughout the
film commonly associated with Krista for
example it's on her face in one of the
visions and sketched out in the
Challenger book that she gifted to Lydia
anyway Lydia burst in the flames and
this in actuality is the beginning of
her attempting to atone for the sins of
her past and that's why there's this
downfall of everything right after this
event so essentially Lydia has to come
clean all of this was spelled out
literally in the first scene of the
movie via the live text message exchange
on the phone with one of the last
messages Bean maybe at the end that
maybe is still a maybe Lydia gets sick
after going into the brothel being
reminded of Olga by the position of the
girl that she picks in relation to where
Olga sat in the orchestra along with the
five being on the robe associating back
to the Fifth Symphony that Lydia didn't
get to conduct but we never see if Lydia
goes through with it or not it is a
maybe but I think this also symbolizes
her growing into her conscience and
having more of a voice of reason because
it physically causes a reaction whereas
any other time in the movie Lydia is
stoic and non-reactionary anyway that is
tar there's so much to talk about this
movie the more I think about it the more
it gets crazy I'm pretty sure that
there's even a teaser that ties in with
the lore of this movie but what did you
think of tar what did you think of
blanchette's performance the messages
that I was trying to say and did you
catch those darn ghosts watching this
movie the first time and I'll let you
know we're currently running a
competition right now giving away three
copies of wakanda Forever on the 15th of
February and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment down
below with your thoughts of tar we
picked the comments at random at the end
of every single month and the winners of
last month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out all
of our other videos Last of Us tons of
content over the last of us you chumps
but with that out of the way thanks for
your constant support I've been Jared
I'll see in the next one take care and
peace